[Music]
today we are checking out not
one but two brand new gimbals from dji
this
is the rs2 and we've also got
the rsc2 so we're going to first start
with the rs2 because i've actually
unboxed this and i've been using it on a
few shoots already then we will check
out the rsc2 and then we'll go outside
and test both of them out
the rs2 is the most powerful small size
handheld stabilizer that dji has
developed yet
it is significantly lighter than the
ronin-s but it's still powerful enough
for larger setups and even medium-sized
cinema cameras
i have actually been using this for a
little bit before i sat down to make
this video
and we have been incredibly impressed
with it i love that it has a built-in
touch screen so you can use this to
adjust settings and it displays a live
camera view when using active track this
does require using the raven eye image
transmission system
this lets you wirelessly transmit to
your phone it'll give you a 1080p view
and a transmission up to a hundred
meters setup and balance on this thing
has actually been
really seamless it has this new dual
layer quick release plates
that you can set up quickly without
having to rebalance every single time
these little fine-tuning adjustment
knobs are so amazing for getting
precise balance before you would always
be nudging things here and there and
then you'd go a little bit too far you'd
mess everything up
and then all of your hard work of trying
to balance just goes right out the
window
there's also some really cool
accessories that you can get for this to
attach to car mounts
jibs and even sliders i've always loved
the built-in creative functions
and this also includes some like time
tunnel motion laps
time lapse panorama and more of which
you can find right on the touch screen
you can get up to 12 hours of battery
life and it supports 24 watt fast
charging so in just an hour and a half
you can get a full charge this is pretty
impressive considering the size and
weight of the battery has been reduced
by about 50
another thing that i love about this is
its little carrying case
this is so small so compact you can
break this down and fit everything that
you need right in here now let's unbox
the rsc2
here we go so this is a pre-release
packaging
obviously it's not going to have this
taped on it
oh it has a carrying case it's like
yes oh look at this
it's like the same style i think it's
basically the same case
look at that
[Music]
this looks like a transformer
i need to figure some things out before
we continue so the rs2 is a more
entry-level stabilizer that has a new
foldable design
so you can transform it into six
different configurations for various
shooting scenarios and for convenient
storage
there's upright flashlight portrait
under sling
briefcase and storage there's a built-in
front dial right above the trigger so
this lets you adjust the camera's focus
when paired with a focus motor this also
has the same dual layer quick release
plates like the rs2 that works with
manfrotto and arca swiss
there's a new mechanical 3xs lock as
well it has a built-in one-inch oled
screen
to check gimbal status or adjust
settings you can get up to 14 hours of
battery life with the two built-in 18
650 cell batteries that are 3 500
milliamps each
this has 18 watt fast charging and will
fully charge in about an hour and a half
and 80 in one hour both of these have
dji's new titan stabilization algorithm
which is their next gen stabilizing tech
to get even smoother shots
there's also a super smooth function
that can be activated for increased
motor capacity and torque for even more
stable shots
even when using a hundred millimeter
equivalent focal length lens
so now that we have all of that out of
the way let's get both of them
side by side and just take a little look
first of all this is obviously made for
higher
end cameras you can get a much higher
payload on this the
red and the carbon fiber finish on this
looks so good you can obviously tell if
this is well equipped for a larger
camera because you have so much more
space
compared to this one so when you're kind
of deciding on which one you're gonna
get
it really does depend on first of all
what's your budget and what kind of
camera are you gonna be putting on this
thing
honestly for us i feel like most of the
time
this is kind of our setup but what i
like so much about this
is being able to fine tune your
adjustments so there's these little
knobs right here so as you can see when
you turn this knob
the plate moves and this will let you
get very very fine-tuned adjustments to
make sure you're getting the most stable
and perfectly even
so here they are let's take them out for
a test
[Music]
do you think i look cool i mean i'm
wearing two patterns of camo
and some really cool cheetah shoes
honestly i would be friends with myself
so this is the first time that we're
bringing them outside
and this one is definitely heavier i
really
love how light this is and i can just
easily
manipulate it and this one we actually
have hooked up to the raven eye
we have active track already set up this
will also send a signal to my phone
when i do have it connected to the raven
eye but it's cool because this is
actually a touch screen
that is another difference between the
two is the rs2 does have a touchscreen
and the other one does not
it has a very small display screen which
will still let you view settings
but you can't touch to control and then
here is the rsc2 i am going to be going
on a trip for the first time in seven
months
so i'm gonna take this one with me
because this one does fold down into a
really nice little storage
uh contraption i can't figure out the
words that i want to say
it folds down to be small this one
actually folds down to be pretty small
too
but i can't take both tyler
what if i take rsc2
you take rc2 and you
can get some cool shots of your kitty
some ronin cat
and whatever other adventures you might
get into over the weekend
cool weekend ronin fun commence
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
made it to maryland tyler just sent me
some of the stuff that he shot while he
was out with rs2 and i have the rsc too
and we're gonna go out and get some
shots and hopefully we can make tyler
proud because
he shot some really cool content are you
ready jen
yeah let's go
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching this
video i hope that you enjoyed it and let
me know if you guys have any other
questions we will be in the comments
answering those and if you want to get
any more information about them
other than what i've showed you in this
video because there's so much more that
i didn't get a chance to cover there
will be links in the description so you
guys can go check it out
i do plan on doing a follow-up video and
a lot of the stuff that i do shoots
in a lot of our daily videos we do use
the dji ronins so i'm very excited to
test these out and you will see these in
action in many future videos
so with that being said i have nothing
else to say
[Music]
end
you